meet trevor hawthorne now known as
d-4651
on the outside he was an armed robber
who murdered two people during a
convenience store shootout in texas
but now since being condemned to death
he's been picked up for d-class testing
by the scp
foundation now also meet junior
researcher dr
julia reed an aspiring foundation
scientist with an undiagnosed heart
condition
the kind of heart condition that doesn't
mix well with a high pressure job at the
scp foundation
these two woke up on the morning of
december 6th 2011
completely unaware of the fact that they
were only hours away from causing one of
the most devastating containment
breaches site 19 had seen
in years many people died that day but
thankfully for everyone else
scp-131 were there to save the day
when you think of a hero you probably
don't picture a pair of little cyborgs
with one eye and the intelligence of a
household cat
but this is the tale of how two of the
most unassuming anomalies at site 19
manage to save
thousands of people from two of the
site's most dangerous
inmates open your eyes and keep them
open
if you so much as blink it's all over
for you
how long can you hold it difficult right
now imagine you're having a staring
contest with an entity that can kill you
if you dare to blink for even a fraction
of a second
or even worse a creature that could
potentially
kill hundreds or even thousands of
people if your attention drifts from it
for any amount of time
try keeping your eyes open with that
kind of crushing pressure
we're talking about two of the most
deadly euclid and ketter class anomalies
out there
scp-173 the killer sculpture
a violent euclid-class entity that is
incapable of moving while being looked
at
if ever it's unobserved it'll snap the
neck of anyone nearby
scp-689 known as hunter in the dark
is an equally dangerous and even more
attention-demanding statue
these two entities are beyond dangerous
even scp-682 is terrified of the killer
sculpture
and researchers have been considering
the use of 689 to potentially eliminate
the hard to destroy reptile for quite
some time
their greatest concern though is whether
the 30 centimeter tall statue would
cause
too much collateral damage to foundation
personnel in the process
trevor hawthorne was part of the
three-man d-class detail meant to clean
out scp-173's containment chamber at
regular
intervals while on cleaning duty two
d-classes can keep staring at the
sculpture while the other tidies up the
cell
alternating turns to blink but that
morning
trevor had woken up in his containment
cell with a killer migraine
and soon that migraine would be killing
far more
than just him the containment procedures
in 689 cell were also a three-person job
689 is a small green soapstone statue of
a skeletal being
sitting on a throne believed to be some
form of underworld death deity
discovered by german archaeologists in
india
this is a work of religious art that
demands your attention
or you and anyone else who's ever seen
this ketter class nightmare will suffer
a horrifying fate anyone who's ever seen
the statue is infected by its anomalous
effects
it must be observed constantly or
someone who's seen it in the past will
suddenly drop dead of a severe health
issue
like a stroke or multiple rupturing
organs
like the god of death the statue
represents it appears on top of the dead
body of whoever it just
killed if not continually paid attention
to
it'll keep hopping from person to person
until it's killed everyone who's ever
looked at it
it's teleporting abilities and the fact
that it poses a threat to
so many make this a truly formidable foe
it's kept in a constantly lit cell and
is observed by two members of d-class
personnel
at all times but a crucial third party
in the containment of scp-689
is a member of personnel at level two or
above
they remain in a control room wearing a
special visor to prevent them from ever
seeing 689
and becoming infected themselves if the
containment fails
it's their job to throw the kill switch
on the d-class observers to prevent them
from becoming vectors
for infection today this job fell on dr
julia reed
she was linked to the two observers via
an audio feed
allowing her to remain in constant
contact with them
and she had her finger on the activation
key for a pair of explosive collars that
were around the d-class's necks
little did they know dr reed's heart was
its own
time bomb now you know what we're up
against
a snap happy sculpture and a teleporting
death statue with a hit list containing
everyone who's
ever glanced at it what can scp-130
bring to the table the two small
cycloptic anomalies have only one
remarkable ability
they never blink that and a soft spot
for humans
these safe class scps pose no threat to
their handlers and can even form
attachments to researchers and other
staff who show affection towards them
of course forming these bonds is
discouraged by site 19's director
because it can be distracting but that
doesn't mean
it doesn't happen the two ipods known as
scp-131a
and scp-131b are identical in appearance
except for their colors
a is a burnt orange and b is a mustard
yellow
the two of them appear to communicate
with one another via high-pitched
squeaking noises
and also seem to have an innate ability
to detect danger occurring in the
vicinity
as well as danger occurring near
individuals they've bonded with
because of their inability to cause harm
and their generally affectionate
demeanor
the ipods are allowed to roam around
site 19
provided they keep out of the way of
researchers and stay out of restricted
areas
they seem to pretty much stick to the
rules though check-ins on a
b are required every hour just to be
safe
as the ipods were moving freely around
the facility trevor and another d-class
maintained a visual on the sculpture in
its containment chamber
while a third man swept up the mixture
of blood and excrement staining the
concrete floors
things were going fine until trevor's
migraine got the better of him
a sudden flash of intense pain shot
through his head
and in a moment of weakness he made a
terrible mistake
with an audible groan of pain trevor
closed his eyes and forced his fingers
to his temples
the groan had taken his fellow observer
off guard and the man's eyes flitted
over to him for a fraction of a second
but a fraction of a second is all the
sculpture needs
in an instant trevor and his fellow
watcher had their necks snapped
and the third d-class was murdered
before he even had a chance to turn
around
containment protocol dictates that the
door is to be sealed behind the cleaning
crew while they're working with 173
but this time perhaps due to complacency
the guards had neglected to reinforce
the door
they got their heads twisted 180 degrees
for their trouble
scp-173 was loose mobile task forces
were dispatched to aid in the
recontainment effort as 173 began
wreaking havoc around the facility but
things were about to get
even worse it seemed like business as
usual over at the containment cell of
scp-689 two d-classes observed while dr
reed dictated to them over an earpiece
from her control center
however what dr reed thought were just
minor chest pains were actually the
onset
of heart failure when the two d-classes
heard their supervisor experiencing a
fatal heart attack on the other end of
the line
they began to panic this meant their
attention wasn't entirely on
scp-689 and they were further distracted
by the chaos
scp-173 was causing elsewhere in the
facility
murdering researchers guards and
maintenance workers alike which led to
power outages
the lights in 689's containment cell
shut down
guards were dispatched to execute the
observers as
is protocol for 689 containment breaches
but the fact that resources were already
stretched thin by the 173 breach caused
a
fatal error in judgement from a guard
posted nearby
in a panic he opened the door to find
one d-class dead with the statue perched
on his body
and the other one running straight for
him in blind fear
the two collided and tumbled out into
the hall both were now infected by 689's
anomalous attention
and both were now doomed moments later
the two of them were dead the statue
perched on their bodies
accidentally catching the eye of several
researchers and guards running to deal
with the 173 situation
for these two deadly anomalies it was
becoming an
all-you-can-kill buffet the staff of
site 19
were now dealing with one anomaly that
needed to be looked at constantly
and another that if you even glance at
it you are effectively infected with a
fatal disease
the ipods sensing an imminent danger
nearby
immediately sprung into action it would
be up to these cute harmless anomalies
to save the terrified staff during this
chaotic double containment breach
in a nearby hallway a fleeing foundation
researcher heard the crunches of her
colleague's necks breaking behind
her 173 was getting closer this thing
couldn't be outrun she turned and saw
the statue standing there
just 10 feet away from her a dead
researcher laying on the ground
in front of it she was locked in a
deadly staring contest with the
sculpture
how long she could survive was now
dependent on how long she could keep her
eyes open
and it was getting harder by the second
she could feel her eyes drying
they burned under the ceiling lights 173
just waited this wasn't a contest she
could win
in a final moment of terror the
researcher was forced to finally close
her eyes and she waited for the crunch
but it never came instead she heard
familiar high-pitched squeaking noises
she opened her eyes crying tears of
relief as she saw
scp-131a sitting behind 173
watching it with its constant unblinking
gaze
the killer sculpture was paralyzed by a
cheerful little safe class anomaly
across the facility a similar situation
had unfolded with scp-689
the statue of death had claimed many
lives but scp-131b had swooped in
and frozen the statue in place with its
never-ending gaze
soon after a mobile task force with
vision blocking visors used advanced
echolocation technology
to collect scp-689 and return it to its
containment cell
everyone who'd seen the anomaly was as
standard protocol
dictates gathered up for later
termination
meanwhile a mobile task force returned
the paralyze 173
back to its containment cell with a
forklift no containment breach is
ever a picnic containment breaches with
multiple dangerous anomalies are even
less so
but the heroic role that scp-131 played
in bringing things back
under control was indispensable after
all
it's not just raw power that counts when
it comes to anomalies
the only anomalous power 131 needed to
save the entire site was its ability to
keep looking when nobody
else could they're so effective in this
role that they've been seriously
considered for permanent roles as
wardens for scps like 173
and 689 and in our opinion they're more
than qualified
now check out scp-999 the tickle monster
and scp-5031 yet another murder monster
for more surprisingly wholesome
anomalies under the care
of the scp foundation